we are here we're going to begin with a
very very special guest what's your name
special guest i'm too very fun
barrymore alive and in color she has
just launched season number two of her
emmy nominated talk show it's called
the drewberry show very clever i like
that and this friday she's got a fun
surprise she's getting back into
character as josie geller from the 1990
movie you remember this never been
kissed
josie will go on special assignment and
we're getting an early first look
that's right it's me josie geller and
thanks for trusting me with this
very important job of talking to the
cast of dear evan hansen
i'm so excited i'm a little nervous but
mostly excited
and i've always wanted to be a
journalist and this is a really great
resume builder i'm here with the cast
you talked to the cast as you see of
dear evan hansen about making the
filming at one point even broke into
song some questions
i thought we were going to see the song
okay
drew mary morning if you could use by
cbs maybe drew could do that
by cbs media ventures a division of
viacom cbs and drew barrymore joins us
in the studio congratulations to you
drew season number two i can't believe
we made it here i know are you what is
your game plan do you
are you kicking up the fun and i only
asked that because when you came out for
the first time in the new york studio
audience number one bravo bravo to
launch a talk show with no studio
audience when you came out in the new
york audience you seemed so happy to see
them that you literally fell to your
knees i did actually did they keep that
in yeah okay
sometimes you know i try to be really on
top of all the edits and the posts but
you know as you're spinning so many
plates um i also like to see objectively
what they choose to keep and you know
good okay great because i did feel that
way that's my honest truth i don't
there i have no calculation i'm very
unfiltered um i care very much about
each detail of the job like going in as
prepared as possible and then letting
all that homework go and just getting
lost and going with it yeah yeah can we
close the loop on the jose grossie
i didn't mean to step on you if you want
to sing by all means but i didn't want
to make you feel oh i busted into song
at their junket because i wanted to
first of all i was very nervous going
into interview amy adams julianne moore
you know amandla all of them
i i i was like and you know we need to
be scared in life when we're too
comfortable
it just is
means it's familiar and that we've done
it and it's you okay he's alright
sniper over there live tv
i love it that's the fun you know it's
like
that's it uh
i was talking to dr lapook earlier and
it's like i also tell our post um team
who's so extraordinary um let's keep the
flaws let's not make it so possible with
right yes i'm not i'm so far from
polished um and i'm a work in progress
and i i like the flaws and it's why we
kicked it off with the la tour of
you know my past and i don't want to
forget all the things i've learned in my
life you even went to a mental
institution i certainly did
it was very candid and very raw that you
seem to be revealing things that i think
many people didn't know
about you i wanted it to be invitational
what do you mean by that i'd like to go
deeper this year uh
as we navigated the pandemic and so many
difficult landmines of necessity that
will reevaluate and recalibrate all of
our lives
lessons and behaviors we should say it's
a mental institution where you were it
wasn't just a random mental institution
yes i was there for a year and a half
when i was uh 13 and 14 and because last
year 2020 demanded so much of us
i had lines of how much i wanted to
ask of people or myself you know i think
i went sometimes more for comedy or
levity trying to kind of pull us
you know i want this show to be a bright
spot not a blind spot
and so this year i think we can go
deeper into people's lives and
conversations but i'm never going to
want to lose sight of comedy i'm never
going to want to lose sight of my love
of food or of course the mood board of
life or the news right yeah the news
news it's everything and you're kind of
i love it
i can't wait i cannot wait nate when i
was here
lucky enough to be covering for you on
paternity leave thank you for that by
the way i marveled at you nate i was
like this is what that electric
connection is when you watch somebody
drew we all did
and look what happened and look what
happened and look i'm here right now but
i want to tap into something you
mentioned going deeper and if you're
familiar with you um as an actress as a
personality and now as a tv host we know
that you love to have fun um i often
times see you and i think to myself is
she spent after she gets done because
you are emotionally invested in every
moment of this and if you're gonna be
going deeper this year yeah how do you
recharge um take out food a remote
control
um
sometimes uh just a moment alone
fighting for that uh in a life that's
very busy and i have kids it's hard to
find that but
i know when my meter is tapped i know
exactly how to fill it sometimes it's
seeing a girlfriend sometimes a lot of
times it's being by myself just
a few hours or a day and it just it
comes seldomly but they are
very impactful and sometimes i just stay
in my house and i just walk around it's
not so bad
with cameron diaz you and cameron are
very tight
but i wrote this down because you and
cameron did something about
these two are happily married so this
conversation didn't apply to them but
you said when it comes dating you should
do hard balling which means treating a
date like a business ceo okay that you
make hard decisions and you make them
fast how do you feel about this i
actually did like that i liked it that's
why i wrote it down mitt romney said
this we'd be making fun of him
is this good advice hardballing
dating like a business ceo make
decisions hard decisions and make them
fast it was a business especially
because you get to a stage in life where
you know
it was a news story that we looked up
and talked about on the andrews news and
i liked it because they're so we are all
contending with relationships yep it's
the thing that unites us you have a
mother a sister a grandmother a husband
a wife a cousin a child
a co-worker
you are contending with some type of
relationship that's probably ever
present in your life sure so the
navigation of those relationships is i'm
obsessed with
um and so any story like that i'm going
to grab onto
because it's interesting and it's what's
trending and i think
why not discuss it i hear you i i did
like that story i like i joke i wrote it
down i don't like it no i i think i'd be
i'd be a bigger believer in second
chances and a slow evaluation because
people come out and and their dimensions
show anyone can when you meet somebody
you don't meet them right you meet their
representative their best face their
best foot forward the real person comes
out later i don't know i think when you
meet me you're kind of this well you're
you're i don't have that you're you
you're the most authentic girl's like
what you get with me
okay immediately and the same with you
jubilee i think we might be hard-balling
options out of our lives because we do
assess very quickly
and i think you and i know what we're
looking for and even more importantly in
relationships just like in design
know what you don't want
and that is the crucial element drew
understands thank you drew barrymore
thank you gail so glad to see we are
cheering you on and nate is going to be
on the show oh i'll try it oh it's going
to be so much fun
i'm back with you and tony thank you so
much for allowing me the privilege of
filling in for you while you took care
of your beautiful baby the pleasure was
mine they're saying we got you drew you
know how time cues go we got it i do for
you so much for having me
[Music]